see this is why we can't have nice
things in my nice things I meet
surprises so the latest trailer for
x-men apocalypse first of all was
anybody asking for this trailer I feel
like they've we've had enough trailers
that most people have made up their mind
as to whether or not they were gonna see
it like maybe one last trailer closer to
when the thing comes out but this is far
enough out that we're probably gonna get
another new trailer even between this
and when the movie comes out so I don't
think anybody was asking for this first
of all it shows us so little new stuff
I'm actually gonna void that I'm getting
really concerned about Apocalypse
himself because they keep using the same
shots they keep using the same voice
over but I asked her Issac has said the
exact same everything they've built will
fall line in every single trailer that
has come out I'm starting to get really
concerned that that line and these few
images that they keep showing over and
over and over again are the only times
the character works the only time he
sounds good the only time he looks good
now I have a ton of faith in Oscar Isaac
I've never seen him turn in a bad
performance but I now feel like they're
hiding him and that makes me nervous but
it's not just Oscar Isaac it just feels
like they're showing us the same stuff
over and over and over again or just
like little additional parts of it every
bit of psylocke we've seen has been the
same stuff I saw I feel like it just saw
slightly more of that same first fight
I'm not saying I needed to see a ton of
other stuff that psylocke did it's just
weird that they're riche owing us the
same stuff repeatedly but this is a new
trailer even though nobody asked for it
this is a new troe they had to give us
something new so what was the one new
thing they decided to throw in oh you
seriously Fox what is wrong with you why
would you put that in the trailer look I
know it may have been rumor and I'm sure
it was speculated and whatever else that
Wolverine would appear in here in some
fashion but it hadn't been made official
there was no official word that he was
gonna be showing up in this movie and
what you have done by doing this is you
have now ruined it for everyone you've
ruined it for all the people who were
gonna go to this movie anyway because
this would have been an awesome surprise
we weren't expecting to get man we booed
a gunman it would have been fantastic
and wonderful and fun and you've also
ruined it for anyone who is now going to
see the movie because you've teased
Wolverine being in it cuz he's
gonna be in it for more than a few
scenes it's gonna be a glorified cameo
they're gonna feel tricked into the
theater the people who are already gonna
go see the movie you spoiled the
surprise why look I know I'm getting a
possibly even more worked up than I did
over Batman V Superman's ruining the
appearances of Wonder Woman and doomsday
this is actually not as bad as that you
don't sort of looked at in a vacuum the
reason I am more angry about it is
because they saw what was done with the
Batman V Superman trailer they saw the
reactions of people going ah why'd you
show us this and they did it anyways I
suspect if they were doubted whether or
not they should tease this that that
went away with the reaction to the
spider-man appearance in the civil war
trailer but there's a big big difference
there which is that anyone who was
following the civil war movie already
knew Spiderman was in there maybe the
general public who doesn't follow in
forums and articles and speculation
maybe they didn't know and it was due to
them but there was a very sizable
segment of the audience who already knew
so that was more of a reveal of the look
up for a fairly large portion of the
audience that would include myself this
this is not the same thing because we
didn't know for sure he was even going
to be in and now you've wrecked the
surprise and now we're gonna be sitting
there the entire time going when's he
gonna show up when what should have
happened is he showed up what I went oh
that's awesome and I'm not gonna do that
now this is something that has become
really bad lately and it's getting to
the point that part of me wants to swear
off looking at trailers anymore I'm not
trying the self-restraint to do that so
I probably will still watch them but I'm
not I don't look forward to new trailers
anymore like first teasers I'll look
forward to but once they start getting
on you know third fourth final trailer
and all that stuff I I don't want to
watch those things anymore it's not
about whether any one given trailer is
any good its trailer overload its
information overload or in the case of
this campaign it's the same information
over and over again plus boiling a
surprise so because of the marketing
campaign x-men apocalypse has gone from
one of my most anticipated movies of
this year down to about where I was
before I went and saw Batman V Superman
which is I'll go watch it I'm not
expecting to have fun anymore that's on
you
that's on your marketing you did that so
what are your thoughts on this whole
freakin mess whatever they are do you
think I'm overreacting am i nuts what
whatever you think drop something down
in the comments and let's talk about it
don't forget to like subscribe check me
out on Twitter right council of geeks
check out the council of geeks podcast
and until next time oh podcast available
on iTunes of the stitcher I'll get it
down but until next time this council is
adjourned